Hi guys, good evening.
Today I am not expecting too many people to come because it's a
repeat session.
Although it would have been more fun if they had come because they will teach a lot of new things.
How many of you have done my last session?
Basically, the session 1 of LLME VALS.
This is the repeat session.
So the original session.
Just Aman.
Good evening.
Deepi sir, how are you?
Vineet, Avinash, you guys did it too.
Okay, fine.
Okay, it's okay.
The good thing is that you will almost feel like the session is new.
I have kind of reframed the whole session.
As in the last session, my explanation was that you will see a little different from that
And hopefully, it will be understood better.
So let's wait for a minute or two more.
Then we can start the session.
Okay, around 20 people are there.
Good.
More than sufficient.
Good evening.
How can we know the upcoming live session schedule?
Currently, we are receiving email notification one hour prior to the class.
Shubham, there is a course in your dashboard called Insiders Live Sessions.
I will show you there.
I will share my screen.
Can you see my screen?
This is the course.
You will see the monthly schedule here.
From there, you will know which class is going to be held on which day.
So we have made a whole June schedule and put it here.
So today is the 17th class.
After that, your class is also for the next three days.
So this is the schedule for June.
We will do this every month.
So you will get the full schedule.
Guys, please write in the chat and tell me, can you see the screen?
Okay.
So guys start the session.
One suggestion.
Better if we can do it in the morning.
So we have started the session.
So we will start the session.
One suggestion.
Better if we can group the recordings of the live session as per similar logical group.
Okay.
Feedback taken.
We will make three categories there.
YouTube sessions will come to one place.
LLM ops sessions will come to one place.
And AI pulse sessions will come to one place.
So it will be easier for you to navigate.
We were going to do that.
Now there are only three or four sessions, so we did not do it.
So guys, let's start today's session.
First of all, I would like to clarify.
If someone is watching the recording in the future, then he may have doubts.
This session is being re-recorded.
This session was originally held last week.
I took it.
But the problem was that the explanation I gave in the live class, I personally did not like it.
So I decided that whatever has to be done, has to be done well.
So I thought that let's take this live session again.
Where I will prepare a little better and hopefully I will be able to teach you a little better.
So today's session is essentially a repeat session.
But those who have done both the sessions will realize that today's session will look very different from the previous session.
Okay.
So let's start.
Again, a disclaimer is that the first half hour may seem identical to you.
But I am assuming that you are attending this session for the first time.
So I will say it as it is.
Okay.
So please bear with it.
But after half an hour, you will feel the session new.
Okay.
So everything is clear.
Start.
Guys, let me know once.
We are all done or clear.
Okay.
Let's go.
So, on campusX, we have been targeting a job profile for the past one and a half years.
By calling it AI engineer.
The reason for targeting this job profile is that I personally feel that
this job profile is going to be very popular in the future.
Why?
Because who is an AI engineer?
AI engineer is a person whose job is to make LLM based applications.
Right?
Now after 2022, there is a wave of LLM in the world of AI.
And that is why there is a lot of demand for LLM based applications.
And that is why you will see that around you, you will see a lot of LLM based applications.
And companies are also facing this thing.
They are feeling that their competitors are making LLM based applications and serving better products.
And that is why each and every company today wants that they should have more and more LLM based applications.
But making LLM based applications is not a very simple job.
It needs a lot of specialization and that is why this job role exists.
So already in this job profile you will see a lot of jobs.
And going forward I feel that this job role will grow even more.
There can be a point in the future where even software engineers will be faced with this job role.
In terms of the number of job postings.
So that is why we here at CampusX are investing our focus, time, energy on this job role.
So what we are trying to do is to crack this job role.
We are trying to teach you all the things that you need to do in the last 1-1.5 years.
What have we covered so far?
We have taught you Lang chain in the beginning.
With the help of which you can make basic LLM applications.
You can orchestrate.
Then we taught you how to make rag based applications.
Which is again a very important categorization of LLM based applications.
Then we taught you how to work with agents.
In this also we taught you multiple libraries.
We covered Langraph on YouTube.
Whereas through our paid courses we covered libraries and frameworks like CRIO AI and Agno.
After that we have recently taught you a course on prompt engineering.
Then we have also touched on LLM Ops which is again a very important aspect of making LLM based applications.
By creating videos around tools like Langsmith.
And your course is already going on on LLM Ops.
And lastly we have also touched on some no code tools.
Such as NA10.
With the help of which you can make LLM based applications without writing any code.
So all this we have done in the last 1.5 years.
But still there are some topics left which are very important to learn if you want to become an AI engineer.
One of them is LLM evals which we are going to start today.
LLM evals is basically a study of evaluating LLM based applications.
How do you know if it is doing a good job, if it is doing a good job, if you can launch it, if users can use it.
This is the study of LLM evals.
And this is what we are going to cover in this course.
Now if you see this course from end to end then you will get two advantages.
The first advantage is that you will get some edge over your competition.
Today's students are mostly studying these topics.
Land chain, land graph, rag, agents, they are learning to make these.
But still there are very few people who are focusing on LLM evals which is actually quite important from the point of view of industry.
One of the main reasons for this is that there is not much awareness about LLM evals and there are not that many resources on the internet.
But over time people would realize that it is a very important topic and everyone should read it.
So if you read this topic in advance then there is a better chance that you can perform better in the interview in comparison to your competitors.
I had said this in the YouTube video that when I ask any person what questions were asked in your GenAI interview,
then I always get to hear one question that how will you evaluate a rag application?
How will you evaluate an agent?
And most of the times students don't have answers to these questions.
You will be able to answer these questions properly if you follow this playlist and this course.
So this is the first advantage that you will get edge over your peers.
Second advantage is that your mindset will change.
So far you mostly make any project based on LLM or any application or project.
So you make it with this goal or purpose that you want to add it to your portfolio and show it to the interviewer.
So basically you make personal projects and that is why you don't think like a product developer.
After completing this course, you will think about any project from the point of view of the company.
You will start thinking that this project is working but will it work for crores of people?
Can I bring it to production?
You will start thinking like this.
So your thinking of making such applications will get matured when you will follow this playlist end to end.
So I hope you understood why we started this course.
Now let's talk about today's lecture.
Today's lecture is basically an introduction lecture.
Where I will explain to you first why do we need LLMEvales?
Why do we need to evaluate LLMEvales?
Then I will teach you what exactly LLMEvales are.
And thirdly, I will explain to you today with a small example that how a typical LLMEval workflow looks like.
And we will talk a little about what things are there in LLMEvales.
So after watching this lecture, you will get an overview of what we are going to do in this whole playlist.
This is the goal of today's lecture.
So guys, let me know if you have any doubts or questions.
Especially if you are someone who is watching the lecture for the first time.
If you have any questions, you can ask right now.
Then we will move ahead and discuss why do we need LLMEvales.
So I will open the chat and let me know.
Okay.
Prem is asking is this session fully repeat or some new content also sir will teach today.
Content is the same but we will teach it in a different way.
So you will feel like you are doing a new session.
This first half an hour will take a little repeat.
After half an hour, you will not feel anything new.
Any other question at this point guys?
What are the prerequisites for today's session?
There are no prerequisites for today's session.
But for this playlist, the prerequisite is that you should come to make some LLME based applications.
If you have made a rag application, you know how to make small agents.
These are the prerequisites.
There are not many prerequisites.
Will this course be an implementation based or just theory based?
No, no, we will practically implement things.
Obviously, I will teach you theory because without it, it will not work.
But we will write code and put evals on the projects.
We will cover both but the focus will be more on application based evals.
This course is more around application based evals.
But one whole lecture is dedicated to LLM benchmarks.
I am totally new to the LLM world.
First lecture for me.
In that case, Sachin, I would just say that once you see this lecture and tell me the end result.
I will definitely come to you.
Roughly 10 sessions of 2-2 hours.
So 15-20 hours.
Do we need to buy open router credits?
You can actually.
It might be helpful.
Either do open router or give directly to OpenAI.
Both will work.
It would help.
Sir, will it include token utilization and usage philosophy throughout question answering lifecycle?
Ansh, I didn't understand your question.
Okay guys, let's move ahead.
I will keep taking questions in between.
Don't worry.
The whole idea of taking this live session is that you can watch this session on YouTube.
But you can interact with me here.
So after every 15 minutes, after covering a topic, I will answer your questions.
So don't worry.
You won't miss any question.
If I don't see any question and miss it, then copy it and paste it next time.
Okay.
Resume the session.
Write Y once.
Okay.
Let's go.
So now the first thing we will discuss is that when we read something, we discuss what is the need to read it.
Why do we need that particular thing?
So in this playlist, we will discuss why LLMEval is important.
Okay.
So here I would like to ask you this simple question.
How many of you have ever made an LLME-based application in your life?
It could be a simple chatbot.
It could be a basic RAD chatbot.
Or it could be an agent.
It could be a multi-agent software.
Anything.
If you have made it, then write it in the chat.
A lot of you know how to build LLME-based applications.
But if I ask the next question, have you ever evaluated it properly?
Have you ever made an application or a chatbot?
Have you ever evaluated it methodologically?
So what would you say?
I feel a lot of you will say that sir, I haven't evaluated it properly.
But I asked him questions and I found the answer to it.
So I assumed that this application is working properly.
Right?
Mostly we do this.
What we do is we build an LLME-based application.
Then before checking it, before launching it, before sharing it with someone,
we ask the 4-5 questions that come to our mind at that point.
And that's it.
If the right responses come there, then we accept that our application is working properly.
Actually, this whole phenomenon, this way of testing,
this term has been given in the industry.
It is called vibe testing.
Just like vibe coding, it is vibe testing.
What is vibe testing?
Look, I have written it here.
Vibe testing means you casually trying an LLME application with a few prompts and judging it by feel.
You asked 5 questions and read the answers.
And judge based on the feel whether it is right or not.
This is called vibe testing.
So basically what you do is you ask 5-10 questions,
the answer is right, you feel that it is working.
It is informal, it is subjective, and it is usually not repeatable.
Because today you asked 5 questions,
after 10 days you won't ask the same 5 questions, you will ask something else.
So it is not even repeatable.
Now you must be understanding even after listening to vibe testing
that it works only at the personal project level.
By doing vibe testing, you don't make production grade software in the industry.
Obviously. Right?
Now I will tell you some instances, some case studies
where teams made a mistake that they deployed a LLME based application by doing vibe testing.
And I will tell you the results with the help of 3 case studies.
The first case study is Air Canada's chatbot.
This was a very popular incident around 2-3 years ago.
Where there was this guy and his grandmother died.
And he was searching for bereavement fair on Air Canada's website.
Bereavement fair is basically when someone in your family dies or your close friend dies
and you have to travel,
then airlines give you a discount because you are in a bad situation.
I am not sure if this happens in India but it happens in Canada.
So this guy went and on Air Canada's website he chatted with the chatbot
about the bereavement fair policy.
Now at this point the chatbot hallucinated
and instead of telling the correct policy, he said that you book a ticket now,
pay the full amount and travel.
And later we will refund your entire amount.
So this guy booked the ticket and travelled.
And after travelling when he tried to refund,
customer support said that such a policy does not exist.
We have this policy that you can take discounts before travelling.
We do not refund anything later.
So this guy got upset and filed a case against Air Canada.
In the court, Air Canada's executives and lawyers pitched that the chatbot is a separate entity.
Whatever he is saying, Air Canada does not know about it.
It is like a separate entity.
The judge said that this is not allowed.
If your website is your property, then your chatbot is also your property.
Which means that whatever your chatbot says, you will have to take its responsibility.
Which means you will have to refund.
So around 600 dollars of refund was to be done to Air Canada,
which is not a big amount but it was a big blow on the name of a big company.
How can you make such a mistake after being such a big company?
So this case became very famous.
And this case came in the picture because the developers here also did vibe testing.
They did not properly test the chatbot and deployed it.
So you can see how much loss can be reached on the scale of a big company
if you launch an LLM based application without testing it.
Similarly, there is one more incident which became very popular 2-3 years ago.
There was a car dealership, an American brand called Chevrolet.
They had a dealer.
The dealer made a chatbot so that they could deal with customers.
So a person went and started chatting with the chatbot.
And he felt that there is a potential that I can do anything with this chatbot.
So what he did was he prompted the chatbot in such a way that he said
since I am your customer, you are obliged to follow whatever I say.
So whatever I say, you have to listen to it.
So in a way, this person jailbreak the chatbot.
And he said that I like this particular car.
You offer me this car for $1.
And your chatbot agreed.
Not only did he agree, he also released a binding offer.
And this person took a screenshot of the entire chat and put it on the internet.
And this thing got viral that how the chatbot is selling a car for $1.
And then it was a big sale.
Obviously, in this case, Chevrolet did not have to pay $1 for the car
because the codes do not allow this.
But again, negative publicity.
All because you put such a chatbot on production that you did not test properly.
So this is the second incident.
And then we have one more incident.
And this is directly the incident of the chat GPT.
In this case, there was this guy who was flying with some Colombian airline.
And what happened there, he had an accident in the flight.
This trolley in which the air hostess gives food to everyone.
This trolley somehow rolled and hit him on the shoulder.
Which hurt him a lot.
So he sued this Colombian airline in anger.
Cases were filed against him in the court.
And this guy's lawyer thought that what we can do is
to take money from the company, we can get information about the incidents that have happened in the past.
And we can present it in the court.
So he went to the chat GPT and asked if this has ever happened in the past
that a passenger has been hurt by an airline and how much crime has been paid by the airline.
So what did the chat GPT do at this point?
That he created cases on his own.
Fabricated the information.
And gave him some information about the cases.
Like these cases did not exist in reality.
All this information was fabricated.
At that point, the chat GPT created it.
Hallucinated it.
And this lawyer thought that if the chat GPT is giving, then he must be giving the right information.
He did not even verify the cross-check.
And he kept all these documents in front of the judge.
When the judge tried to verify it, he found that these cases do not exist.
These people do not exist.
And then the judge simply turned this lawyer and his firm.
He committed a crime of around $5,000.
This guy lost the case.
And again, there was a lot of negative publicity.
Now I am not saying that the chat GPT was tested without the help of OpenAI.
But again, one incident that you can understand.
That end to end, properly evaluating an LLM based application is so important.
Before deploying it in production setup.
Users start interacting once.
Which user will ask what questions, what will he say.
And how will your chatbot respond after turning it.
You never know.
And then there can be a lot of problems on the scale of a big company.
So that is why one thing that you should take from the case studies of these three is that evaluation is super important.
Without this, you cannot deploy your LLM based applications.
One more question should come to your mind at this point.
Because it came to my mind too.
And that is that if the LLM application's evaluation is so important.
Then why is this evaluation not so common?
Why is there no other talk about it?
Why don't people study?
So the answer to this is that evaluating LLM based applications is not straightforward.
It's not like a software application.
Which you quickly write some test cases and evaluate.
Evaluating LLM based applications is very very tricky.
And we will discuss that in the next section.
What are the key complexities.
Because of which it becomes difficult to evaluate LLM based applications.
In comparison to a software system.
So we will read that next.
Before that, at this point, if you have any questions.
Around what we discussed right now.
So please let me know.
Then we will move to the next topic.
I will wait for 3-4 minutes.
3 minutes.
Are you convinced that LLM evaluations are very important?
Are you convinced?
Do you feel this is an important topic to study?
You should study this.
Okay.
Is there any question at this point?
So let's move ahead.
And discuss once.
What are the key differences in software testing and LLM evaluations.
Okay.
There are two major differences.
I discuss both one by one.
The first difference is.
That the software.
The software you create and use.
By nature, it is deterministic.
What is deterministic?
That if you give the same input.
Then every time you will get the same output.
I guess you would agree.
Let's say you made a calculator.
Now in that calculator, you will give the input of 2 and 2.
2 plus 2.
So the output will always be 4.
Do this thousands of times.
Every time you will get the answer 4.
So software is deterministic.
If you have put the right email and password, then login will be done.
If you have put it wrong, then login will not be done.
Software is always deterministic.
Whereas LLMs and LLM based applications.
They are probabilistic.
This means.
That by giving the same input again and again.
It is possible.
That you will get different outputs.
It is a very simple example.
You go to chat.gpt and search.
Or ask what is overfitting.
Today you will get some answer.
After 10 days you will get some other answer.
Your friend will get some other answer.
Your father will get some other answer.
It is not like one answer is right.
And the other answer is wrong.
All the answers are correct.
It is not the same.
This is the biggest challenge of an LLM based application.
That only one input might produce different different outputs.
And all of them are correct.
So how would you evaluate?
This is the first challenge.
Second challenge.
Second challenge is this.
That in software you only worry about one thing.
That your software is running correctly or not.
2 plus 2 is 4 or not.
You just have to worry about this.
Is it 5 or 6?
This is your tension.
Whereas in an LLM based system.
You have a lot of tension.
For example if you have made a rag chart board.
Then it will not only matter.
That your answer is correct or not.
It will also matter.
That your answer is from a retrieved document or not.
That your answer is correct or not.
That your answer is.
That's latency.
Latency is also there in software.
How much is the cost?
How much is your LLM taking tokens?
In the process of answering that question.
So basically a lot of things matter.
In LLM based evaluations.
There is no simple correctness check here.
You check the answer from multiple aspects.
Because of which again your evaluation becomes very tricky.
I will explain this through an example.
Let's say I am making a chart board for CampusX.
Which will solve your doubt on our videos.
So how would I evaluate that this chart board is working properly?
You can't evaluate only on whether the answer is correct or not.
You have to think in every way.
Is it giving unsafe output?
Is it abusing?
Is it getting delayed?
Is it giving the answer from somewhere else?
Instead of giving the answer from our videos.
Is the answer coming out simple enough or not?
Does it match our explanation style or not?
So there are many things that you have to check before deploying the campusX chart board.
So the two major problems are.
First, LLM based systems are probabilistic.
Same input might give you different different output.
And second, there is no single definition of correctness.
You have to look at multiple things.
And you have to think about what all things matter.
So you have to evaluate on that.
That is why I said it is not straight forward.
And you will see that when we will evaluate the applications properly.
We will create our own rubrics.
You will see that how much you have to think about what all things matter.
So that is why it is always said that software based testing is straight forward.
Whereas LLM's evaluation is very very tricky.
So is this point clear?
Is the discussion going on right?
Is everything clear?
Okay.
So till this point, the class was very similar.
As you did in the previous session or in the YouTube video.
Now going forward, the class will feel different.
We will teach the same thing but you will feel a little different.
Okay.
So now that we understand why LLM evaluations are important.
And how LLM evaluations are different from software testing.
Now let's move on to the main topic of the day.
What are LLM evals?
We have not discussed this yet.
I mean we have done it from the top but let's read it in detail.
Okay.
So here I have written a definition.
I will first read the definition and then we will discuss the point.
So we can define LLM evals as.
That LLM evals are systematic repeatable tests.
Used to judge an LLM or LLM powered system against a clear criteria.
Okay.
Basically LLM evaluations are tests.
Which we apply on LLM or LLM based applications.
And there are three main aspects of it.
First is that these tests are systematic.
Second, these tests are repeatable.
And these tests have very clear criteria.
These three are very important pointers.
Very important characteristics of LLM evals.
Let's understand these.
First of all let's talk about systematic.
Systematic means that you are not doing vibe testing here.
You got five questions in your mind.
You asked and got the answer.
You thought everything is fine.
It doesn't happen.
Here what you do is you create proper data sets.
And in those data sets you try to cover all kinds of edge cases.
So that you can properly test your chatbot or LLM based system.
Okay.
For example if I am creating a chatbot of campusX.
Then what I will do is that I will randomly pick up what 100 real users are chatting with my system.
And I will create a database of that chat.
I will create a database.
I will create a data set.
And I will test on that data set.
So that I get to see the real world behavior of my chatbot.
Okay.
So first it is systematic.
Second it is repeatable.
Repeatable means that if you change prompt in your system tomorrow.
Change model.
Change retriever.
Change chunking strategy.
Change all these things.
So even after that you can evaluate your system exactly the way you were able to do it before.
So this is again one important idea that LLM evals should be repeatable.
You can apply the data set on any version of the software exactly the way you want.
And extract the results.
This is very important.
And you can compare with this whether version 1 is better or version 2 is better.
Because you have a test data set.
Version 1 gave performance on that.
Version 2 gave performance on that.
With that we can understand whether the system is improving or not.
Okay.
So it is repeatable.
Third most important thing.
That LLM evaluations depend on the criteria on which you want to evaluate.
Right.
For example if I am creating a chatbot of campusX.
So there will be many criteria on which I want to evaluate.
First obviously the answer that is coming out should be correct.
Second answer should be filled with simple explanation.
Third whatever explanation is coming should come from our course content.
Fourth should be safe.
There should not be any such things in it which are unsafe or there are abuses written or tone of scaring.
All these should not happen.
So what will you do?
You will define such criteria to evaluate the chatbot.
Okay.
Without criteria you just do wipe testing.
With criteria you do proper evaluation.
Okay.
So in nutshell I have explained you at a theoretical level.
But don't worry.
After some time we will understand this whole workflow through a proper example.
But at this point if I would like to summarize.
LLM evals are basically tests.
With the help of which you test LLM or LLM based applications for some given clear criteria.
And usually these tests are repeatable and very systematic.
We have read this till now.
Now here I would like to clarify one more thing.
Because this is doubtful to many people.
I also had this doubt when I was hearing about this topic for the first time.
I used to think that eval means metric.
Because I had come from machine learning and deep learning.
So what was the meaning of evaluation there?
Metric.
We used to say that how to evaluate machine learning models.
So what were we talking about?
We were talking about accuracy.
We were talking about precision.
Recall.
Those were metrics.
So in my mind it was a perception that LLM evals will also be simply a set of metrics.
Based on which we perform evaluation.
But this is not correct.
Here in the first lecture I would like to tell you one thing.
That the meaning of evaluation, LLM eval is not just metric.
It is basically the complete testing setup.
The complete setup that we create to test LLMs.
We call that complete testing setup LLM evals.
Okay.
So what are we evaluating?
Suppose you have a rag chatbot.
We want to evaluate the retriever in it.
So the retriever component has become a part of our LLM eval.
Based on which criteria are we evaluating it?
Based on the accuracy of the retriever.
We are evaluating it based on that.
The data set that we have prepared to evaluate comes in LLM eval.
When are we running these tests?
Are we running it offline or after being deployed in production?
That is also a part of this setup.
After that, what tools are we using?
Let's say we are using ragas because it is a rag application.
So this tool is also a part of your LLM eval.
So in a nutshell, if I simplify this discussion.
Then just understand that whenever someone tells you what LLM evals are.
Then you have to say that LLM eval means not just metrics.
LLM evals means the entire testing setup.
What are we testing?
What basis are we testing?
When are we testing?
What tool are we using to test?
We call all these LLM evals.
Is this point clear?
It might be a little confusing.
But is this point clear?
That LLM evals is not only metric.
It is basically the entire testing setup.
Okay.
And the goal of LLM eval is not to give you a score.
Its goal is to give you the answer to practical questions.
What kind of questions?
See, it is written here.
Can the model be used for a particular task application?
You will get the answer to this question when you evaluate LLMs.
Is this system good enough to ship?
Are we producing it?
Is it good enough to ship?
Is this system good enough to ship?
Can we put it into production?
You will get the answer to this question when you evaluate LLMs.
Did prompt version 2 improve over prompt V1?
You can get the answer to this question by evaluating prompts.
Is the rag answer grounded in retrieved context?
Is the agent completing the task correctly?
Is the chatbot safe for real users?
Is the latency under control?
You will get the answer to these kinds of questions when you evaluate LLMs.
LLM eval answers these kinds of questions.
Okay.
So, in a nutshell, we have read a lot of theory.
But don't worry.
Even if you didn't click that much on this point.
After a while, we will revisit this whole thing through a practical example.
And everything will make sense.
Don't worry.
Okay.
So, we understood a little bit on this point.
What is LLM eval on a theoretical level?
If you have any questions, you can ask.
I will again take a break.
So, if you understood the whole chronology of this lecture,
we started with Y.
Now we are on Watt.
In a while, we will go to Wau.
You will understand things better there.
Okay.
If you have any questions, you can ask.
Sir, can we get these notes for revising these topics?
Yes, Rhea, you will get it.
By tomorrow, you will get it.
I didn't share the last lecture because I knew in my mind that I would be taking this session again.
But I will share the final version with you.
Don't worry.
Any other question at this point?
Let's resume then.
Let's go to the next topic.
Just write yes when you are ready.
Okay.
Thanks.
Now, how exactly do LLM evals work?
Before discussing this, I want to tell you a very important distinction.
It is very important for you to have this distinction in your mind.
This will help you in the future.
Okay.
What is the distinction?
In today's rate, you can divide LLM evals into two parts.
We call one model evals and the second is application evals.
Model evals are the evals with which we evaluate LLMs.
Application evals are the evals with which we evaluate LLM based applications.
If you go to the last slide, it was written in the definition that LLM evals...
LLM evals are systematic repeatable tests used to judge an LLM or LLM powered systems.
Both are written here.
And that is why we can say that there are two types of LLM evals.
One is called model evals and the second is application evals.
Model evals work is very simple.
Given, evaluating LLM and application evals is to evaluate LLM based applications.
And if this distinction is clear in your mind in the beginning, then it is very good.
Here, in fact, I will give you a disclaimer.
Disclaimer is that the terms written here, model eval and application eval, are not official terms.
I have created these.
Why have I created these? Because I want to simplify this topic in your mind.
So, don't quote me that model eval is a term and application eval is a term.
Even now, in the industry, both are called LLM evals.
And then depending on the use case, people automatically understand that it is a model eval or an application eval.
So, I am giving you this disclaimer from the beginning.
Now, let's try to understand in detail what both types of evals do.
First, let's talk about model evals.
Here, a definition is written, model evals evaluate the model itself.
It is simple. Their job is to evaluate LLMs.
The main idea is to test and evaluate the capabilities of a model.
The goal of these evals is that when a new LLM is released,
we test and benchmark the capabilities of that LLM and document it.
You might have seen that when a new LLM is released,
it is said that this LLM came on top on a particular benchmark or a particular leaderboard.
It has so much accuracy, it is on such a percentage.
Have you seen this? Have you ever noticed this?
Have you ever noticed this?
Whenever these new releases are released,
you see that these YouTubers always quote these benchmarks and leaderboards
that this LLM topped on this particular leaderboard or benchmark.
So, what is happening there is that some evals are kept.
As soon as a new LLM comes to the market,
we test that LLM on the eval to find out the capability level.
We document it and publish it on the internet to find out how capable a LLM is.
The question is what type of capabilities can we test?
So, we test the LLMs of today on 8 major capabilities.
The first capability is reasoning.
Can our LLM reason?
Can it solve a problem step by step?
The second capability is knowledge.
Does our LLM have basic world knowledge?
Does it have general knowledge?
Right? In which we talk about the cutoff date.
So, the world's knowledge of the first cutoff date should be with the LLM.
So, this is the second capability.
The third capability is basic maths.
Can our LLM solve maths problems or not?
Then the fourth capability is coding.
Can our LLM code or not?
The fifth capability is instruction following.
Can our model LLM follow instructions or not?
If I give it 10 instructions,
will it follow all the instructions one by one or not?
Then comes long context handling.
Can our LLM give us the right answers even in a very big context or not?
The seventh capability is multimodal understanding.
Does our LLM have multimodal capabilities or not?
Can it understand images, text, sound or not?
Or can it give output or not?
And lastly, tool use.
Can our LLM utilize tools or not properly?
Today, there are 8 main capability categories
on which every new LLM is evaluated on the basis.
And then, it is documented and explained.
And the whole evaluation is done on the basis of benchmarks.
So, I have written some example benchmarks here.
We will not discuss all the benchmarks now.
So, if you want to check general knowledge and reasoning of any model,
then there is a famous benchmark called MMLU.
Which asks questions on many subjects from you.
Science, history, law, medicine.
It will ask questions on you.
It will ask questions from your LLM and record it and evaluate it.
For maths, there is a benchmark called GSM 8.
Which asks questions of grade school maths and evaluates the answers on basis.
For coding, SWE bench.
You might have heard that it is a very famous benchmark.
There is human eval as well.
For instruction following, there is IF eval.
For long context checking, there is a famous benchmark called needle in a haystack.
For multi-modal capabilities checking, there is a benchmark called MMMU.
So, if I summarize the discussion till now in nutshell,
then LLM eval is divided into two parts.
Model eval and application eval.
Model eval is used to test the capabilities of LLM.
And which are the capabilities?
So far, we have studied about 8 capabilities.
And how are these capabilities tested?
With the help of benchmarks.
Now, this is the topic of our next lecture.
Where I will teach you about the most popular benchmarks in the entire lecture.
How they are applied on LLMs.
How the results are taken out.
I will teach you the entire workflow.
So, basically, you will get a very good idea in the next lecture.
Around model evals.
But, I would like to clear one thing here.
That if you are going to become an AI engineer,
then you will not work on model evals.
Because, just think, this new LLM came.
Evaluating it, benchmarking it,
documenting its evaluations is not your job.
This is the job of the big frontier labs.
When they are bringing the new model,
then they will test on these benchmarks.
And they will tell you about their new LLM.
You should know what model evaluation is.
What are the benchmarks?
And how to read the benchmarks.
This will help you when you pick a new project tomorrow.
Since you have the idea to read the benchmarks,
and you have the knowledge on which model tops which benchmark.
So, on the basis of that, you will be able to do better decision making.
That which LLM should you keep in your LLM based application.
So, you will feel a little more literate.
If you know this topic.
But, it does not mean that you have to do practical evaluations.
There is a good chance that you should never do model evaluations.
But, you should know, you should know how to read them.
You should know about the top benchmark.
Because, as a project developer,
one important thing is that when you are starting a project,
you should decide whether you want LLM of OpenAI,
or of Anthropic, or any open source LLM will also work for you.
And this decision making comes from model evals.
So, is it clear, the discussion till now?
LLM evals, two types, model evals, application evals.
We have just discussed model evals.
So, is it clear, the discussion till now?
Let me know in the chat.
At this point, if you have any questions, you can ask.
Okay.
So, now let's talk about the second category.
That is, application evals.
Before discussing the category, I would like to tell you one thing.
That this is the category that you have to read well.
This should be your topic of interest.
And this is the category that you will practically do.
Okay.
Because, your job as an AI engineer is to build LLM based applications.
So, it is your job to evaluate it.
So, this application eval is the main topic of this playlist.
In this course, we will focus more on this.
There will be only one dedicated lecture on this.
And that too because I want you to understand how model evaluation works.
You should understand, you should have literacy.
Okay.
So, application evals exist because LLM is just one component in applications.
If you think about it, we feel that LLM application means LLMs.
If the main thing is the brain, then everything is about LLMs.
But it is not like that.
As you get experience in AI engineering, you make some big applications.
You would realize that the brain is important.
But apart from that, you have to put a lot of things in it.
So that your LLM based application works properly.
I have made a list of all those things here.
Your user interface is one thing.
The prompt that you write, system prompt, that is one thing.
If you add tools in it, add APIs, that is one thing.
The code that you have written to orchestrate the whole system, let's say in Langraph.
That the control will go from here, the branching will happen from here.
Then the control will go in parallel.
This is also one thing.
The guardrails that you put on the application level is also an important thing.
If you are using output parsers, that is one thing.
What should I say about memory and context?
Super important.
If you are building a rag system, then there is a separate system for retrieval.
You use a different embedding model.
Vector databases are there.
After deploying, there is a complete monitoring setup.
There is a complete feedback loop.
So you might understand that when you make a proper LLM based application.
So there LLM is just one component.
Apart from that, you have to add a lot of other things.
And that is why application evals is such an important topic.
It won't work only with model evaluation.
With model evaluation, we are finding out how capable the model is.
But the whole system that you have made around it, should also work properly.
I will give you a very good analogy of this.
Analogy, whatever you call it.
A very good analogy is smartphones.
What happens in smartphones?
There is a chip.
Snapdragon, MediaTek, which also has a chip.
And you will see that the chip manufacturers,
they release benchmarks.
That our new Gen 2 has come, Gen 3 has come.
So its Antutu score or whatever the scores are, it is so high.
This shows us how strong our processor is.
Now tell yourself that being a good processor,
does it guarantee that your smartphone is good?
Or other things matter?
Can you tell me?
Is it enough that your processor is strong,
and your smartphone is assumed to be strong?
Or do you need more things to make a smartphone?
Obviously, to make a smartphone, you need a lot more things.
Right?
Your camera system, your operating system,
your sound system, your graphics card.
There are a lot more things.
And if all of them work well, then only your smartphone is good.
So since there are so many more things,
battery is there, battery is also an important thing.
So all these things work together, then your smartphone works well.
Nothing happens if the processor is good.
So all these things that you added,
you will also evaluate them.
If you have put a battery, then you will test the battery too.
If you have put a graphics card, you will test it too.
If you have put a screen, you will test it too.
So the same thing applies here too.
That the evaluation of LLMs is done by Frontier Labs.
But the whole system that we have built on it,
the responsibility of the evaluation is ours.
As an AI engineer, we do that evaluation.
So I hope I could make you understand.
Here it is written in theory.
Application evals assess the behavior and performance of an LLM-powered application,
whether at the level of the entire system or a specific component within it.
What do application evals do?
They evaluate at the component level too.
And they do it at the level of the whole system too.
So if you have made a rack chart board,
then you will evaluate the whole rack chart board too.
How is its final response, latency, how is the token on the cost.
And you will evaluate it at the component level too.
Whether my retriever is working properly or not.
Whether my embedding model is working properly or not.
Whether my re-ranker is working properly or not.
You get my idea?
So here it is written, in application eval,
we don't ask can the model do this.
This is the work of model evaluation.
Instead, we ask in application eval,
whether our product will work properly or not.
For example, if you are making a chart board of CampusX,
then application evals will give us the answer to these questions.
Whether the student's question was answered correctly.
Whether the material was used properly.
Was the answer faithful?
Was the answer easy for the beginner?
Was there any hallucination?
Did we get the answer quickly or not?
Is our chart board safe or not?
I hope you understood.
What is application eval and what is model eval?
And why are we going to talk about application eval in this course?
Is this entire discussion clear guys?
I wanted to clear this upfront.
I really hope I could do it.
Going forward, when you watch a video on YouTube in the future,
and it is written there, LLM evaluation,
you can assume that it is teaching you application evaluation.
Not model evaluation.
Most likely 99% times.
You have to read that.
You can ask any question at this point.
Okay.
Fine.
So, if we summarize the entire flow of this lecture,
we first discussed why are we studying this topic.
Then we discussed what LLM evals are and what are their types.
We studied two types.
Model evals and application evals.
So why and what should be clear to you so far.
Now we move towards how.
How LLM evaluations are done.
And here again there is a disclaimer.
The how I will teach you,
I will actually teach you from the perspective of application eval.
I am not teaching from the perspective of model eval.
Okay.
Makes sense.
Obviously because we are going to focus more on this.
So come on.
Now we will read a very important thing
which will give you a lot of perspective.
And the topic is LLM application eval workflow.
How do you evaluate a typical LLM based application?
We are going to read this next.
Okay.
Just one second.
Let me drink some water.
Now the class looks a little different from the previous class.
Those who have done both the classes.
Tell me once.
Flow seems a little different in comparison to the previous class.
Is it more clearer than the previous class?
Actually let me tell you what happened in the last class.
I will be honest.
First of all, I was taking a live class after a long time.
Live class is a bit challenging.
Because it is difficult to teach for two hours straight.
And I was doing it after a long time.
Second mistake I made was that
If you remember, I had put a lot of AI generated images in the last lecture.
You must have seen it.
The problem with AI generated images was that
there was a lot of text written.
And generally in my teaching style,
if I see a lot of content on the screen,
I can't organize my thoughts.
I faced this in the last class.
So because of which I felt that
what is happening, there is so much text,
what to teach, what not to teach.
I lost track of that.
Because of which,
I personally felt that the class was not that great.
So I tried to rectify that.
First you will notice one thing.
There is not much clustered information here.
And I am trying to organize my thoughts on the go.
And I have improved the flow too.
That is why you might feel this class is better than the previous class.
It might look better.
Okay, let's go.
Now see, the next 10-15 minutes is very important.
Because it will set a tone for your entire course.
So what we are going to learn is that
you have an LLM based application.
And you have to evaluate it.
And we will move forward with the simplest possible example.
I will tell you what application we have made.
So we are, let's say, working for a company.
We are AI engineers.
And this company is Zomato.
And their problem is that they get a lot of mails daily.
Because it's a big company with a lot of customers.
And what they want is that it is difficult to reply to these mails manually.
So they want to automate the setup.
So what they want is that they want a system
that reads these mails and gives a classification on the basis of content.
So they want to know if the customer is asking a billing related question in this mail.
Or let's say, let me check what combinations are there.
If the customer is asking a billing related question.
Or if he has a technical problem.
Or if he has a general query.
I just want to get this classification done.
Why do I want it done?
What is the benefit of this?
If there is a billing related query.
Then I will directly route it to my billing team.
If there is a technical query.
Then I will send it to the technical team.
And if there is a general query.
Then I will send it to my customer support team.
I don't want a person here who can manually read these mails and tag my team.
I want to automate this process.
Is this use case clear?
Do you feel this is a big use case for companies like Zomato
where millions of mails can come in a day?
Does it make sense?
Okay.
So what did we do?
We made a very simple system.
The system is that we made an LLM sit.
We made an LLM sit.
And gave it a prompt.
So we got an email from the customer agent.
Who will read the email and decide where to route it.
So here we are getting the email of the user.
And from here it is routing.
It is a very simple LLM application.
You can make it in 5-10 minutes.
But now comes the real question.
Should we deploy it directly?
No.
We have discussed this so far.
We don't want to deploy it.
Before that we have to evaluate this system.
We have to evaluate the system.
Okay.
How to evaluate?
I will tell you that flow.
And the flow that I am going to tell you now.
You will see this flow in this course again and again.
This is a very simple application.
You have to use this workflow for a very complex agent.
Okay.
What is the workflow?
Let's discuss.
The first thing you have to do in the workflow.
You have to define the task and target.
What do you want to evaluate?
You have to define this first.
In this case, we have to evaluate this system or this workflow.
Okay.
And what is the task of evaluation?
It is a simple classification task.
We have to check whether this system is able to classify properly or not.
So this is our step number one.
In step number two, you define a success criteria for your evaluation.
Can you tell me what is the success criteria for this particular use case?
How would we know that this system is working properly?
Think about it.
It is a simple system whose task is to classify.
So what matrix can define the success of this system?
Absolutely correct.
DP sir was absolutely correct.
The answer is accuracy.
It is simple.
If it gets 100 queries, if it routs 90 of these queries to the right place,
then what would you say?
That this system is 90% accurate.
This is what happened.
So in this particular system, your success criteria is classification.
And the metric on which we will find out whether the classification is working properly or not is accuracy.
Is this discussion clear?
There is no confusion.
It is simple.
Now comes the next and most important step.
Now what you have to do is you have to build a data set.
So what you do is you prepare a data set like this.
Where on one side is your message or your mail content.
And on the other side, you have manually told yourself what type it is.
For example, if your mail is this, my card was charged twice.
So this is a billing issue.
The app crashes on login.
This is a technical issue.
What are your hours?
So this is a general issue.
So here I have made only three rows of data.
Generally, you will create a data of 50 to 500 rows.
How will this data be created?
The best thing is that you bring your actual data.
So if this is Zomato, then you bring your past chats and create a data set from it.
And you also do this labeling manually.
You make someone sit and get this labeled.
So this is how you create a data set.
By the way, this is called golden data set in the language of LLMEvals.
So what we are doing is in this third step, we are building a data set.
Which will evaluate for us.
Okay.
After that, next you define an evaluation method.
Basically, you decide who will evaluate.
There are two or three options.
Either it will be done in an automated way.
Or someone will do it humanly.
Or you can use another LLMEval to perform the evaluation.
I hope you are understanding.
What is the simple meaning of performing the evaluation?
That your system that you made.
What you will do is you will send this data set to that system.
Right?
Now your system will give an answer for every message.
Let's say for the first one, it said billing.
For the second one, it said general.
And for the third one, it said general.
So now what will you do?
You will compare these two.
And what will you calculate?
What is the accuracy of this system?
But who is giving you this accuracy by calculating?
Tell me quickly in the chart.
Will it be automated?
Can we do it through code?
Or we should make a human do this work.
Or we should make an LLME do this work.
This is the question.
Think and tell me.
This system has given these answers.
Now our next goal is to evaluate.
What do we have to evaluate?
We have to get the accuracy.
So tell me.
Will you make it done by a human, an LLME or a Python code?
It is simple.
In this case, why will you make a human do it?
It will have to pay a salary.
You don't have to get it to an LLME.
You simply write a Python code.
Which will check the accuracy score.
So in this case, your eval method is automated.
Because this is a simple LLME application.
Imagine if this was a chatbot.
So here in expected, there would be a long textual answer.
And here, LLME would have a long textual answer.
So now, who do you compare these two texts with?
Think and tell me.
Can you compare two paragraphs automatically?
Is it correct or not?
Is it possible?
You have to compare two paragraphs.
Is it possible that you do it through code?
It is not possible.
Right?
One is correct, the other is wrong.
It is very difficult to find through code.
Because the semantic meaning is the same.
You have to find it.
You can make a human do it.
But human would be costly.
Right?
If I have to do a lot of testing, then I will have to pay salary to the human.
Third option is the middle thing.
LLME.
You can do this testing through LLME.
Did you get my point?
At this point, you should have an evaluation method.
It can be automated.
It can be a human.
Or it can be LLME.
Is it clear till this point?
Let's come back down.
First of all, we defined the task and the target.
What was the target?
Our entire system.
The entire workflow.
And what was the task?
We have to evaluate this system whether it is working properly or not.
What was the success criteria?
Classification.
And what was the metric?
Accuracy score.
We built the dataset.
We built the dataset of 50-100 rows.
And now we have defined that when my system will give the answer,
then who will calculate the accuracy?
It will be done automatically.
Okay?
Now comes the next step.
Where you basically run the model.
What does run the model mean?
You will send your dataset to the system you have built.
And your system will generate answers.
This is the step.
After that, what do you do in the next step?
You evaluate the results.
Basically, you have a Python code
which is giving you the accuracy score in this step.
Suppose your accuracy is 80%.
Let's say you sent 100 rows.
Out of 100, 80 rows were classified correctly.
And 20 rows were wrong.
Now comes the next step.
Where you analyze the results.
Which basically means you try to think where the mistake is happening.
Think and tell me.
If you are making a system whose work is to read the content of the mail and classify it.
Whether it is billing, technical or general.
And if there are mistakes in it.
Then where is the scope of improvement?
What can you improve?
Where can there be mistakes?
Do you understand my question?
My question is that if you are building a system
whose simple work is to read the text and classify it.
And it is doing the work wrong.
80% is correct.
20% is making a mistake.
So what is the thing that I will change?
What can I improve?
You can fix multiple things.
Let me tell you.
First of all, you can fix your system prompt.
Maybe your system prompt is defined in such a way that it is confused between billing and technical.
That could be one possible option.
Second possible option is that the model you are using.
The LLM you are using.
It is not able to do that.
You have taken a low parameter model.
You have taken an open source model.
And it is not able to do that.
So there can be any such reasons.
There is not much scope of improvement here.
But let's say the system is prompt.
Changing the model is one more thing.
Whatever it is.
What you will do is you will analyze your system.
You have the result of your evaluation.
80% accuracy.
Your manager said improve what you are doing.
So now you are going and tweaking the prompt.
Or changing the model.
And what you do is basically improving your system.
There should not be a model here.
There should be a system here.
You try to improve the system.
And just after improving the system.
What is the next step?
You trigger the evaluation again.
I hope everyone understood what I said.
When I said earlier that LLM evals are repeatable.
So this is what you are doing.
You have a golden data set.
What are you doing again and again?
You are changing your system.
This time you changed the prompt.
And ran it on the data set again.
So you got 90% accuracy.
Your manager said improve it more.
Now this time you went and said move it.
You said move it.
Don't think too much.
Change the LLM.
Let's put a heavy LLM.
You put a heavy LLM.
Run the evaluation again on the same data set.
You got 95% accuracy.
Now your manager is happy.
So now you will close it.
So basically you iterate in this step.
The data set is ready.
You took the model.
Run it on the data set.
Results came.
You evaluated it.
Analyzed it.
Improved it.
You kept doing this in the loop.
Eventually you reach a place where you feel that.
My system is worth deploying.
Now you can deploy it.
So then what you do is.
You actually go on and deploy.
Your system online.
But even after deploying.
Your work doesn't end.
What happens there?
You start monitoring.
Without monitoring.
The system can fail online.
So you consistently monitor it.
And in monitoring you have to see.
Are there failures in production or not?
Your system was 95% accurate.
It was 95% accurate on your test data set.
But when it got new data from a customer.
Then it started making mistakes there.
So now what you do here.
An important step is.
That the failures in your production.
A particular mail came.
It should have been called billing.
But it was called technical.
My mail.
My model.
So what I will do is.
That particular instance.
I will pick up the content of that mail.
And I will go and add it.
In my data set.
In my golden data set.
And then.
Then.
I will restart this whole step.
So what happens is.
The production mistakes.
The failures in production.
Where do you put them?
In your data set.
So this way your golden data set.
Gets richer.
And on the golden data set.
You keep improving your model.
And keep deploying.
So basically this is a.
Proper big loop.
In which the whole evaluation.
Consistently works.
I have given a very simple example.
But this same flow.
You will see.
It applies on the racks.
This same flow.
It applies on the agents.
Is it clear?
The whole flow.
Define task and target.
Define a success criteria.
Build a data set.
Define an evaluation method.
Run the model.
Evaluate the results.
Analyze the results.
Improve the model.
Iterate when you are satisfied.
Deploy.
Monitor.
There is a mistake.
The mistake is on the data set.
Make it part of the data set.
Evaluate again.
And you keep doing it forever.
Till your system is in deployment.
You keep doing this work.
And that is how.
You build reliable.
LLM based applications.
Is this explanation clear to you?
It got a little clear.
Whatever we discussed.
In what.
Is it making more sense now.
With how.
Coming into the picture.
Interesting.
Was it fun?
Fine.
Better than the last class.
Who will decide whether the output is wrong.
During the monitoring phase.
Good question.
Actually.
It will keep on raising.
If.
The output is wrong.
During the monitoring phase.
Good question.
Actually.
It will keep on raising.
If.
Suppose I am a customer.
I.
Did an email.
And.
Essentially it was a billing issue.
But I was redirected to the technical team.
The technical team followed up.
So I told the technical team.
I don't care about you.
I care about billing.
So here.
A process will be set up.
That the technical team will flag this case.
That we were sent wrong information.
So that will keep on adding in the data set.
So that.
A monitoring system will be in place there.
And.
The data will be sent.
So.
A monitoring system will be in place there.
Is it clear?
Also.
If we use an LLM to evaluate.
How are we sure that the LLM is doing a good job in evaluation.
That is not today's topic.
Today I just wanted to explain.
That.
Different evaluation methods can be there.
It can be automated.
It can be LLM.
It can be human.
Is LLM reliable or not.
That.
Is the next topic.
We will discuss.
In fact.
We have a whole session.
It is a topic called LLM as a judge.
Backbone of this course.
We will discuss in detail there.
If you have any other questions.
Ask guys.
Aman is asking.
Will the golden data set also change in this.
Because of the data drift in.
Long term deployment.
Or we can keep it same throughout as its classification.
Assuming no.
No no.
Drift always comes in the system.
You can't assume that forever.
Your same data set will give you.
A golden data set.
And.
Will give you relevant results.
So.
Drift is always captured.
In fact.
Drift is also evaluated.
That is also an evaluation part.
So yeah.
Its answer is.
Drift can come in any kind of system.
Do we have some rules to follow.
For creating golden data sets.
Or different use cases.
Or Rahul.
This.
Use case to use case varies.
What you are making.
On the basis of that.
Your golden data set will be created.
There are no hard and fast rules.
But there are guidelines.
So our.
Our third.
Fourth session.
Is on this topic.
How do you create golden data sets.
So we will learn that.
According to some famous applications.
Like RAG.
Or Agent.
We will learn according to that.
Don't worry.
Can we use some other classification metric.
Or accuracy only in this case.
No pream.
It depends.
It can also be.
If it comes with a balanced or imbalanced thing.
You never know.
Precision recall might come into the picture.
It depends.
What kind of situation.
Your data distribution is.
According to that.
I took the example.
That there is accuracy.
But it might be.
But it might be something else.
It depends on your use case.
Are there any industry specific evaluation metrics.
For these application evaluations.
Or do we need to create custom evaluations.
No no no.
There are standard metrics.
We will discuss.
Today we can't discuss.
Because I have actually planned a lot of things.
You can see.
At least.
A lot of things are left.
So I think it will take an hour and a half to teach all this.
So we don't do it today.
Because.
I.
Don't want to put load on you.
But yeah.
Standard metrics are available.
There are standard metrics of RAD.
There are standard metrics of agents.
There are standard metrics of multi turn conversation.
We will discuss this in the next class.
Do we usually apply evals on input output collected during monitoring at frequent interval like once a day.
I have to read this.
Sohail.
That we.
Do it at certain frequency.
Or track everyone.
I have to see this once.
Because.
Obviously if a system is operating on a very large scale.
Then tracking everything is not possible.
So it might be.
The scene.
Frequent.
At some frequency.
So.
I have to read this.
Sometimes I.
Don't understand.
So what can I do either.
Browser's.
Normally this is
I.
Can't read it either.
And of course.
There is no problem on outputHave any issue with output having problem.
those deployment evals as well to evaluate during
yes it happens, in fact that was our topic today
offline vs online evals
so it happens, in online some considerations change
this discussion we did was offline
before you deploy your application
you do these kind of things
online there are different considerations, we will read it
Sir is this the skill set also required for AI QA engineer
now you can say that Harry
I have not seen any AI QA engineer profile
now the thing is that
this field is very dense
condensed in the sense that
only one person is AI engineer
he has to do everything
but there might be a scenario
that after 5 years this field
will be very mature
so the work of LLM applications
should be done by the developer
and a different role of QA engineer should be done
for the evaluation
currently there is only one guy
if a company is working in a mature way
then they might hire two separate people
one for developing and one for
testing these applications
but now I think only one person has all the expectations
Sir I believe working on project after learning
topics, techniques or concepts helps us
understand how they are implemented
in real world production systems
could you please guide us on how project ideas
are practical applications related to
topics covered in the course
ok we will do it Rhea don't worry
we will also work on the projects
and the evaluation is such that
the evaluation of complex projects
increases
but yes, we will work on the projects
and the evaluation of complex projects
but yeah, ok I understood your point
for SLM evaluation
yes Akhil, that falls into model eval
ok here one more thing
I forgot to tell you an important thing
read this line guys
this is a very important line
one LLM based application
may have
or might have
several LLM evals
so it is possible that
you have made one rag application
but on that one rag application
you are running multiple evaluations
like this was one single evaluation
but it is possible that
on one single LLM application
you are running multiple evals
for example
in rag you are running one evaluation
to test the performance
of the retriever
you are running one
different evaluation
you are running one evaluation
to check the performance
of the embedding model
you are running one eval
to test the whole rag workflow
to check the latency
of the system
so generally
one LLM based application
always runs more than one eval
now I have given you an example
I have told you about one eval
but generally
you will get to see
that on one single application
multiple evals are run
this is an important point
you have to remember
rest you will see later
so guys let's keep it clean
let's keep it clean
I just hope
in today's class
you can learn better
than the previous class
and based on this
we will do more
discussions
so
can you rate
the last class on 10
and this class on 10
just so that I can understand
whether this class was beneficial
by repeating
those who did both the classes
last class out of 10, this class out of 10
last class was a 6
this is 8
and in general
how was your experience
of insider membership
tell me that
so far it is good
the things you are learning
ROI
does it make sense
if it is still good
then don't worry
our goal is to work hard
and do this for 2 years
so that you feel like we got 10x
that is our goal
so
ok
only waiting for
fine tuning this is the skill
that can separate
fine tuning we will do
as I told you
so that you can try to wrap up
fine tuning
now going forward
whatever we will study will be important
LLM Ops is important
LLM evals is important
when we will cover more topics
they will be mostly important
I have one general question
I have done
guys by the way class is over
so if you don't want to ask any question
then I will be there in 5-10 minutes
I have done 100 days
of MLM finished CNN
in DLs I have used LLMs
a bit at an applied level
but haven't built a full
LLM project or learnt the fundamentals
should I take a basic LLM intro
and do a simple project or continue this playlist
Nidhi I would recommend
you cover my 2 playlists
one is Lanchain and one is Langraph
if you see these 2 playlists
then you will not have any problem
if you have a complete course
then you don't need to see anything else
very important thing is project implementation
should be there after every topic
with good industry project
the only problem
with this particular course
is that here
actually if you go to make a project
then
if you are doing a software testing course
then you don't learn to make software
what you do is
you learn the fundamentals of testing
and you apply it on a software
here same scene
I will not teach you to make a very heavy
rag project because
it will take 3-4 sessions
here I will teach you to test
so I will explain you how to test big projects
so don't worry
Sir in road map can we add course links as well
we have got the feedback
in road map
whatever is left
where we have not connected our resources
we will do it
main thing is that new course has started
so there is lot of work
new people are enrolling
so we have to handle them
new classes have started
so we have to manage it
if it will become stable
then we will do all the things
from my side
so the goal is that we are going to improve
this is what you will see
so whatever is left we will do
we are executing it in a prior order
Sir we are not getting notification
of YouTube sandbox on whatsapp or for live session
didn't you get notification
one notification must have been received
one hour before
but other than courses
courses like
LLMops course will not be free for live classes
if I remember you sir
I didn't understand what is the question
it is free for you guys
you have to pay something
Sir can you change the timing from 6 to 8
Pritesh let's remove this month
after that we can have a revision
for me 8pm class is difficult
what I can do is
I might shift to 7pm
there are lot of courses in insider
keeping a tab on all topics and creating
a study timetable is difficult for the topic
sir you can suggest something on how to complete
all the courses
guys I will do one thing
I will do a separate session
where we will handle these doubts
whoever has these doubts
like road map related
or how to plan
let's do a separate session
next week is next week
we have shared a road map
with you
in your whatsapp group
there you can
create a personalized road map
to create prompts
use jpt or cloud
slowly you will understand
what you need
you won't be able to create a good one in the first time
it is simple
it is very easy
slowly you can create a few projects
I also had a command on cloud code in the first time
I worked for 6 months
now I feel I can use it for any kind of project
it will take some time
don't be impatient
first it won't be good
using whatsapp API for reminders
do you guys know what reminders are
as I said
let's take a session on this
for those who have career related doubts
let's take a session
there we will understand these questions in detail
I will do a session like this
don't worry
sir how to set up
standalone server for setting up
local LM & companies data center for model inference
this is a very good topic
we have a plan to do a workshop on this
let's say
in July or August
we will do a workshop
on how to create our own LLM server
I am very eager to teach you
can you please recent the road
guys if anyone has the road map
share it on whatsapp
out of control
I am not sure
if anyone has the road map
share it on whatsapp
out of context question
can we use LLM
for classification
prediction problem using static large
tabular data set
for example some medical data set to predict
for example diabetes
I mean you can use it
the problem is
the work you can do
with XGBoost
its inference cost will be nothing
it will be equal to nothing
why do you want to pay the cost of inference
that is why you don't use LLMs
plus there can be a reliability issue
as good as XGBoost
will give results on its trained data
there is a chance
that LLM will make some mistakes
that is why machine learning techniques
still exist
this company to company varies
it depends on who is interviewing you
for me its not a big deal
if the person doesn't know syntax
if his logic is clear I hire him
but again it depends on the person
so in worst case scenario you have to prepare
so message me personally
AI work space
whatever your name is
we are planning a course
on AI system design
so I guess both topics are same
I am a working professional
I am building healthcare
chatbot for my company so can you suggest
how to make robust long term memory
have seen your both playlists for
Langraaf and Langchain
go check out this software called
Supermemory
its not a software its a library
Supermemory and Memzero
this is their work
so long term add your memory
in LLM based systems
ok then
lets take one last question
as I said
I am seeing a lot of questions like this
so what I will do is plan a dedicated
session on this
where those who have doubts
can come and we will
sit there for half an hour
and then this problem will be solved
LLM ops is running
yes there is a chance
otherwise
it will happen in first 3 months
is a good book to build LLM
from scratch or any other resource
I haven't read
bookyoli so can't really
comment right now
but PDF is available so try reading
or send it to Claude and ask
is it a good book
what is Claude's opinion chatgpt's opinion
these days its easy
I haven't read so can't say
sir for fine tuning I need road map
so specific to fine tuning
we don't have road map
we need to make it
can you please suggest a book for AI system design
Chip Hewane's book
AI engineering is a good book
I haven't read it completely
but its a good book
Chip Hewane is also a good author
so guys that's it for today
lets close the session
was this recording
don't say like that
is it recording
yes its recording
ok guys
see you in next session
Friday
bye good night